[Music]
on this wednesday night israel and gaza
on the brink of war
dozens are dead as rockets rain down and
violence spreads
to the streets the most important thing
now
is for all sides to cease
the violence who has the authority to
intervene and de-escalate the conflict
mixing it up can pairing different
covid19 vaccines create a stronger
immune response our fingers cross
a preliminary study canada is closely
watching
plus is at the end of the line for
enbridge's line five
michigan's deadline to turn off the pipe
arrives
and this rocks the nasa spacecraft on
its way home from an
asteroid with a payload of deep space
samples
global national with donna friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
fighting between israel and gaza is
escalating tonight
in a conflict that has flared up over
decades this is the worst violence
in years the u.n is warning it could
escalate into a full-scale war
israel bombed another high-rise in gaza
sending warnings before it leveled that
14-story building on the busiest
shopping street in gaza
top commanders from hamas and islamic
jihad were killed and
hamas is now calling for a full-scale
intifada or uprising
the death toll on both sides is rising
israeli airstrikes have killed at least
65
people in gaza according to the health
ministry there including 16 children
and a fierce barrage of rockets from
gaza has killed seven israelis including
a child
and a soldier the u.s hasn't been
actively engaged so far but tonight
president joe biden said he has spoken
to israel's prime minister
and said that he expects the violence
will end sooner rather than later
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
it is the heaviest fighting in years and
militarily
it is one-sided israel's precision
airstrikes have destroyed the officers
of hamas leaders in gaza
and they have killed top hamas
commanders inevitably civilians dozens
so far have also been killed
meantime rockets fired from gaza by
hamas are less accurate and often
intercepted
but have killed some israelis while
raining hundreds of missiles down
mostly on tel aviv israel's prime
minister has vowed to increase israeli
airstrikes
[Music]
benjamin netanyahu declared today we'll
hit them like they've never dreamed
possible
the fighting was sparked by recent
unrest where jewish settlers tried to
take over arab-controlled neighborhoods
part of the decades-long dispute over
expansion of israeli settlements
this area in east jerusalem is
considered among the holiest territory
by both israelis and palestinians
at recent protests a senior hamas leader
vowed not to leave palestinians
to face the israelis alone
jerusalem is a powder keg for
any kind of immediate conflict this
academic says peace
in this area will require compromise and
new leadership on both sides
there have to be leaders that come to
power that are interested
in solving the conflict which will
inevitably involve
a two-state solution but the political
backdrop is highly unstable
there is a power struggle for leadership
among the palestinians
while israel's netanyahu has failed to
form a government
opposition parties are closer to
toppling him from power and the
international backdrop has also changed
after u.s president trump's total
support for israel
washington under president joe biden is
only now engaging diplomatically
adopting a more traditional stance
israel has a right to defend itself
palestinians have a right to live in
safety and security
and the most important thing going
forward now
is to take down the violence
to that end washington is sending a top
official to meet with palestinian and
israeli leaders
many governments don't want to deal with
it right it is a fault line
for instability in the region
and the united states really can't
ignore it
the middle east has confounded
peacemakers for generations
and the worry now is that the conflict
may spread to the entire region
pushing the prospect for peace even
further into the future
eric sorensen global news toronto
for palestinians living in jerusalem the
latest eruption of violence is
devastating and
familiar tonight we're getting a picture
of what life is like for them
in a city that is home to some of the
holiest sites in the world and where
people
of different faiths have lived worked
and prayed for generations
freelance reporter new ham mosley spoke
to people about what's inflamed the
anger
one of the major developments during
this year's holy month of ramadan
in the old city of jerusalem was israeli
ban of palestinian presence
inside the mosque and outside of it
we are very angry it's a
very bad thing
to to do for muslims
in the last days of ramadan
of our holy month in our holy place
to muslims residing here al-aqsa mosque
is central to their well-being and
personal dignity
for us al-aqsa mosque is our life
our future and it's part of our
faith and religion it is something that
is
should not be touchable in nearby sheikh
jarrah
28 families are brooding over the fate
of eviction
from their homes of 61 years built on
land
which the jordanian regime has provided
for them when they became refugees
in 1948. i lived in this house
65 years and they want to took
me from here to through me to the street
me and my children
and my wife and my brother and my
grandchildren that's not easy you know
how do we advance
how do we go forward how do we resolve
outstanding issues that need to be
resolved
and if this doesn't come then we
it's going to recur again and again and
again
the continued frustration of
palestinians
makes them desperate to see change
either the occupation will overwhelm the
whole country
or liberation will take place either us
or them however when a palestinian woman
is challenged about the negative
consequences of the rockets
from gaza hurting innocent civilians in
israel
she justifies this behavior we are in
arabic saying
who is knocking the door he's received
the answer
global news jerusalem now to the
pandemic and the continuing turmoil over
the future of the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
more provinces are now restricting its
use because of both supply and safety
concerns
today nova scotia announced it is
halting the use of astrazeneca as a
first
dose because of the risk of rare but
serious blood clots
the decision to pause the use of
astrazeneca is based on caution
science and the availability of
alternative mrna vaccines
from pfizer and moderna
british colombia alberta saskatchewan
manitoba and newfoundland and labrador
have also stopped offering astrazeneca
as a first dose
those provinces gave varying reasons
from ongoing evidence to
supply issues most of the coveted
vaccines in canada right now
are mrna vaccines from pfizer and
moderna
but more astrazeneca is on the way the
federal government says it expects 655
000 doses from kovacs to be distributed
next week
more than 250 000 of those are earmarked
for ontario it's not clear though when
or if ontario will
use them the health minister christine
elliott said today the government is
waiting for a safety review before
deciding what to do
that means there is a chance some of the
vaccines could expire
we don't expect that there will be
any or perhaps just a few doses that may
expire
however this is out of an abundance of
caution
because the safety and well-being of the
people of ontario has to be our top
priority
one potential solution to the concerns
over astrazeneca is to mix
doses so that people who got astrazeneca
as their first shot
could get a different vaccine as their
second research is still underway into
whether mixing doses is a good approach
tonight there are some promising new
early findings from a study in the uk
crystal gomencing has the details just
as vaccines are becoming routine a
potential
new path to immunity
the study found no additional safety
concerns from administering a first shot
of oxford astrazeneca
followed by a pfizer booster or the
other way around
when compared to using two doses of the
same vaccine
but more people who received mixed doses
reported mild to moderate reactions
after their second
shot infectious disease specialist dr
gerald evans says
that's a good sign so one of the things
that tells us
in a way is that there may be
a more robust immune response happening
with
mixing the vaccines it's an
interpretation that is widely supported
and if
accurate would give countries including
canada
vaccine flexibility the chief trial
investigator says
it is too soon to say if mixing leads to
enhanced immunity
but matthew snape says the current data
can still influence decisions
one of the things that's telling us is
that for example you wouldn't want to
immunize a ward full of nurses
on the same day with a mixed schedule
because
they may have higher rates of
absenteeism the next day
many canadians are open to vaccine
mixing
especially as provinces pause the use of
astrozenica over concerns related to
rare but serious blood clots
or supply limitations i'll take what
comes when it comes there's some
intriguing preliminary evidences that
suggest that it might be beneficial and
yeah i don't mind a little experiment
once in a while
any vaccine mixing that does happen
would be an
exception not the rule according to the
scientific director of ontario's covet
19
science advisory table what we need for
that
is real data lab data on
how hey how high the antibody levels
will be and how
the cellular immune reaction will be
more results from the oxford study
are expected in the summer and a
canadian study
is in the final approval stages crystal
commansing global news
london the legal battle over line five
coming up the looming threat as a
deadline to turn off the tap to a
pipeline passes
plus simply the best this year's
inductees
into the rock and roll hall of fame
americans are lining up for gas at
hundreds of stations today there is a
shortage because of the cyber attack
that led to the shutdown of a major
pipeline
and that has led some to hoard fuel
filling up gas cans and huge barrels in
the backs of pickup trucks
any container they can find some
apparently even filled plastic bags
though it's not certain if these
pictures
are from today just in case though the
u.s product safety commission tweeted
this reminder
use only containers approved for fuel
the colonial pipeline is the largest
refined fuel pipeline in the u.s and
late today the company said it has begun
restarting operations
late this afternoon gas pipelines are
lifelines for people and industry and
the canadian government